Okay, we're now going to talk about Bit Torrent,
which is a peer to peer content distribution
network that is commonly used for file sharing
and distribution of large files. Okay, suppose we have
a network with a bunch of clients, all
of whom want a particular file and the file
might be particularly big. Now, those clients could
all fetch the same file from the source, or
the origin. But the problems with that of
course, are that the origin may be overloaded and
the act of making this request for a
large file from the same location on the network
may also create congestion or overload at the
network where the content is being hosted. So, a
solution is to fetch content from other peers. Rather
then having everyone fetch the content from the origin,
we can take the original file, and chop
it into many different pieces and replicate different pieces
on different peers in the network, as soon
as possible. So the idea is that each peer
is assembling the file, but it's assembling it
by picking up different pieces of the file. And
then it can retrieve the pieces that it
doesn't have from the remaining peers in the network.
By trading different pieces of the same file, everyone
eventually gets the full file. The idea is that hopefully
we'll be able to assemble the entire file at the
end by the time all of the clients have swapped.